the story i love you went in on an
audition for liberty records
you wanted a record contract and you go
into audition i played jim reeves he'll
have to go i played
put you put your sweet lips a little
closer
to the phone
and let's pretend that we're together
all along
tell a man to turn the jukebox
and you can tell your friend there with
you
he'll have to go
that's what i played and i was looking
for a record contract or a writing
contract and then
obviously he thought who needs another
jim reeves and
and then there was the pile of lyrics on
the table and he just picked an envelope
gave it to me i opened it on the train
and there it was bernie
it could have been any lyric he gave me
but happenstance was
that's why my life is so incredible that
it happened to be bernie
and it worked out he could i could have
been riding with fred smudge
um and it wouldn't have been bernie it's
been the longest relationship i've had
with anybody really
except my family out of all the
craziness went on there was bernie he
was there
he was there he came to the treatment
center he gave him the lyrics he did
this he did that
he was the thing the glue that held me
together
even though we weren't together living
together
i'm so lucky to have had that kind of a
relationship with someone
you know you don't have to be around
someone all the time to be best friends
we're best friends and the distance
between us has kept us close
are you playing piano every single day
of your life still i never played the
piano hammer i've never ever played the
piano at home unless the boys asked me
to
are you sure my seven-year-old came down
the other day and went i could play deep
purple
is that spoke on the water yeah it is
i can play deep purple the other one
plays the fur i don't play at all it's
like
why would i want to play i mean people
like rufus wayne right get up and play
every day
that's them i play like 120 shows a year
why would i come out it's like if you're
in a bakery and you work
five days six days a week what do you
you come home and make a [ __ ]
apple pie straight away no you would not
no but to keep your fingers and to keep
your no no
no i do i play tennis i do arm exercises
do you ever wake up and have a song in
your head and you go
no seriously you don't have a song in
your head right now like i said you out
what's in your head right now
really i never think of melody's first
ever you always need a lyric i need
a lyric wow it's bloody odd and
it is it's it's it's strange and it's uh
but it works and i've never questioned
it and i've never thought
you know should i write people say you
know what you should write the lyrics
because you're very verbose you're well
spoken you're erudite
and i said that's a great disservice to
people who actually write great lyrics
because it's not easy to write a great
lyric so when bernie sits and gives you
the lyric
what do you do he usually gives me a
bunch of lyrics at once and i go and i
look at the titles and i think
i'm in the mood for that title so um for
example if tiny dancer is so californian
it's all
it's very california so if i get that i
meant my red block quite quickly and
it's like
it's very west coast blue jean baby
it just is when i see the lyric then i
see
the movie i see the movie of the finnish
song and i know which direction to go in
like philadelphia freedom was obviously
going to be a philadelphia
soul record um the process of riding
with bernie has never gotten old from
those beautiful early demos
it's exciting now to get a lyric from
him because i never know what
the movie is going to be